so you can illegally buy heroin on the
corner and then walk into a safe space
where they're going to give you a clean
needle and a iodine or an alcohol kit
for your point of injection okay and by
the way the um opioid antagonist in
modern parlance that's like an EpiPen
like when people have uh like when
people have allergies you have to carry
that behind like a child with peanut
butter or bee sting it's it's a it's a
big adult version of that oh you're
having a oh the guys have an overdose
hit him with the Narcan right yeah
exactly similar exactly right
um hit him with that so it just is
shocking to me it's it's this is really
shocking why why would we help to
perpetuate someone's situation with such
a drug like heroin and bad Brown is is
is is the hardest to kick you know as
they refer to as what they call their
harm so-called harm reduction policies
isn't it have you you guys read us but
where's the methadone helping these
people maybe to get off it back to some
other place no no I'm I have you guys
read a San Francisco no question Michael
schellenberger have you read that book
I've not read it but I've I've seen a
lot of the stuff yeah I I'd really
recommend reading that book because I
went to California for the first time in
my life in 2019.
um and I was I was shocked by LA and San
Francisco I saw stuff in those two
cities I'd never seen anywhere else in
any City in my entire life and this is
2019 and stuff in many cases wastes
worsened since then but those places are
they're not normal my mind was blown I
was so confused I was in San Francisco
for a week and I was like interview I
was like informally interviewing Uber
drivers and everyone's like what is
going on in the city why is it why is it
like this I mean I remember being out
there and I was in a park it was 8 P.M
on a Saturday and there were like 20
people just shooting heroin in the park
behind me just just casually I I was
I've never seen that before just out
there in the open people walk talking
past going out to clubs going to
restaurants and whatever it's just
people doing heroin I was like this is
not normal and then I was so intrigued
by it and I got led to this book and I
was reading about it and the history and
why the policies are like this and so on
so this does not surprise me in the
slightest
um but it's insane these places I've
described California as a a beautiful
place run by complete idiots I think
it's run by complete crazy people with
no grasp on reality and um it's sad it's
sad because San Francisco is a beautiful
city architecturally whether in La is
fantastic these are these are cool
places but
policies are just nuts on so many levels
and they just keep getting worse it's
almost like they're trying to drive
people out
in San Francisco in 2018 2019 and I was
with my girlfriend at the time and we
checked into our hotel cool we got we
were so excited we drove from La did the
what is it the 101 Highway up in
California yeah did the drive uh Big Sur
have you ever drift through Big Sur it
is ridiculous talk about gorgeous forget
about it and then we get to say we're so
excited it's the New York City of the
West you know it's like and we get
checked in a hotel and we asked the um
the bellhop or the uh the person in the
front desk which way to go they go
definitely don't walk that way yeah like
because it's night time don't go that
way go this way even that way
long story short my girlfriend she's
like dude we get like what the [ __ ] is
this city get me out of here yeah I go
we're here for four days let's give it
some time we'll stay up tomorrow and we
went to like Fisherman's Wharf and we
and it was actually really nice yeah uh
but there are parts of it that are
absolutely insane disgusting like what
the hell is happening here yeah and
that's the most expensive city to live
in America New York San Francisco so
it's like there's this ridiculous
profound wealth because of the big Tech
and everything that's gone in Silicon
Valley and then there's just this
disgustingness that's happening
on the underbelly not even so much the
underbelly because it's out there it's
in the center but it's it's just like
this backwards thing and and on the
surface even this story is disgusting
all right so I can come in and do heroin
professionally what a mature way to do
heroin and I've lost some friends to
overdose whether it's opioids whether
it's you know this kind of crazy stuff
and I'm trying to wrap my head around
why they would Implement policies like
this yeah and the only thing that I can
really come up with is the fact that
while these people are going to do it
anyway yeah so they're trying to prevent
deaths and overdoses and sharing
disgusting needles and if people are
going to do it anyway why not allow them
to do it in a safe space now I'm not a
I'm not an advocate of heroin or pills
or overdosing but there must be some
methodology to the madness yeah I think
it's kind of um and a lot people on the
you know kind of far left progressives
can have this type of
almost like toxic compassion it's the
opposite of tough love they're
completely opposed to tough love right
it's this
but but it's to the you've ever seen
those programs where someone weighs like
600 pounds or 700 and you know their mom
is still feeding and why are you feeding
because I because I love him like
everyone like they're so unwilling to
enact anything that is just like look
you can't do this so it's so permissive
that it ends up being destructive yes
right actually I fully agree with you
yeah it's the same they've done you know
with the shoplifting right you know you
can shoplift up to 900 across criminal
damage up to 900
um and it's not a felony right or the
the way that they have the tens and
they're the people just injecting or
whatever as long as you're not you know
physically assaulting someone but here's
what I'm gonna ask you guys I want to
ask you guys this question so so tell me
this policy of creating a safe space for
heroin addicts to go use heroin
I want to hear from who the hell says
what an honorable thing to do like give
me be the Devil's Advocate and don't
think logically okay okay and and go to
the person that says that maybe they
lost somebody to heroin or like who's
gonna say
man what a great idea sell me that can
you even do that like do you understand
what I'm asking I I think I do okay I
think I know how they come from it I
think there's there's two perspectives
there's the number one
this is where I'm not
this is this is one thing where I'm not
sure I I don't think my the libertarian
thought process really works on this one
but number one is the whole
your body your choice you're not hurting
it you're not hurt as long as you're not
hurting anybody else you should have the
right and it should be legal for you to
consume whatever you want put whatever
you want into your body so there's that
there's that libertarian approach of
just like well that's up to you has
should have nothing to do with the
government so on and then there's the
more
um Progressive side which I believe they
call these Productions uh the sorry they
call these policies harm harm reduction
which is as you alluded to people are
gonna do this anyway so it is safer for
them to be using clean needles and to
have some staff in case they overdose
and people who know how to use Narcan
and so on that is they're going to do it
anyway so it's better for them to do it
in this type of environment so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]